(applause)
- Okay, so, Charlie, you recently
had your wisdom teeth pulled.
So, here you are in the car
afterward. I love these videos.
- Is it okay?
- Yeah, it's cause they put medicine.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
Where is she?
(sobbing)
She might be working.
- It's all right.
- It's okay.
I love her, Dixie.
- I love her, Dixie.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applause)
It's the weirdest thing,
how much I love watching people
coming out of the dentist
office in these videos.
Do you remember any of that?
- I remember my whole face
was really, really numb.
- Oh.
- It was definitely,
looking back at the videos,
I think I had a really good reaction.
I did not know what to expect
at all, especially after.
- Oh yeah, that's right, that's right.
We actually, we didn't leave Dixie out.
We actually have hers, as well.
We want to be fair here.
Let's play Dixie's.
- Mom, literally I'm fine.
Let me eat anything.
- Not now, honey.
- Why?
- Because.
- Please.
I just want a burger.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applaud)
- Literally, I'm fine.